[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I'm
going to skip my preamble to get to the
guest today Neil Ferguson you can find
him on Twitter at
nfergusn-f-e-r-g-u-s m-a-d-fill f-r-s-e
we may get into what that is is the
Milbank family senior fellow at the
Hoover institution Stanford University
and a senior faculty fellow of the
Belfor Center for Science and
international Affairs at Harvard he's
the author of 16 books good Lord that's
a lot of books including the pity of war
the house of Rothschild Empire
civilization and Kissinger
1923-1968 the idealist which won the
Council on Foreign Relations Arthur Ross
price he is an award-winning filmmaker
too having won an international Emmy for
his PBS series the ascent of money his
2018 book the square and the tower was a
New York Times bestseller and also
adapted for television by PBS as Neil
Ferguson's net World in 2020 he joined
Bloomberg opinion as a columnist and
addition he is the founder and managing
director of green mantle LLC a new
york-based advisory firm a co-founder of
a Latin American Financial technology
company and a trustee of the New York
Historical Society the london-based
center for policy studies and the newly
founded University of Austin his latest
book Doom subtitled the politics of
catastrophe was published last year by
penguin and was shortlisted for the
Lionel Gerber prize Neil so nice to see
you thanks for making the time Good To
Be With You Tim and guilty is charged
all of you just said Is is true I cannot
deny it all of the things and we're
going to unpack all sorts of bits and
pieces of that and I wanted to start
with
a an observation and you can correct
this observation if it's a if it's an
illusion a mirage a misreading of the
facts uh Noah Feldman says hello by the
way as a side note hello back to Noah he
put into words something that has struck
me about your career and that is that
it's not really one career you have at
least three careers so major historians
so the best of the best played the Ivory
Tower game brilliantly well then public
historian slash public intellectual we
could we could parse out or relabel any
number of those and then afterwards you
have advisory firms and the company
involvement and so on the first question
I want to ask related to this and
certainly you can revise that but what
was your first experience in reaching a
broader public with your ideas outside
of of Academia
I always felt that
if I was gonna be a historian
it should not be for some tiny exclusive
audience confined to Ivory tars whether
in Oxford or Cambridge or or Harvard
my hero when I was a Schoolboy was a
British historian ajp Taylor
who not only wrote terrific books I
think the first history book I remember
engaging with was his Illustrated
history of of the first world war but he
also would write newspaper columns and
do lectures on television and get into
public rows and that all struck me as a
highly attractive way of life
you would be in the morning sitting in
your Oak paneled studies surrounded by
by books uh smoking your pipe and giving
tutorials but in the afternoon you'd
bash out a thousand words for the Daily
Express and then you deliver a quick
lecture on the 1848 revolutions for the
BBC and then you'd be in time for a high
table at seven so that that was always
the plan
I never aspired to be a Dryer's dust
academic uh at all in fact it it it's
striking how how successful they have
executed a plan that I hatched when I
was a teenager
so this leads into
I suppose a question maybe even part
answered it which is
uh let me set the table by saying I have
a lot of involvement with friends in
Academia with researchers who are
de facto involved in academic settings
and there's a lot of fear-based career
planning in those circles uh sort of
seeking a Prestige and social support or
endorsement you seem to have
been a skeptic of whatever container
people have attempted to put you within
and have become an iconoclast in in many
respects
is that lack of fear what appears to be
a lack of fear
something that was developed is it
simply because you had already hatched a
plan to leave the confines for instance
in in the one case of Academia therefore
you weren't worried about them booting
you out
where does that openness to criticizing
what's around you come from
well you have to remember that I'm old
I'm 58 so well my career you've been at
it for a while though yeah by the launch
Zone in the mid-1980s When I Was An
undergraduate at Oxford was very
different
compared with the launch Zone at a
Harvard or a Yale or a Stanford today
and I'm not sure it's possible to be me
today in fact it it almost certainly
isn't we forget that the 1980s were a a
high point of of academic freedom
because academic freedom is not
something that's always been there it
had to kind of be fought for
in the later 20th century and I was one
of the beneficiaries of
a tremendous climate of intellectual
freedom in Britain in the 80s the
battles had really been fought in the
60s and 70s or earlier and we took for
granted that we could say the most
outrageous things
calculatedly offensive things and pay no
price I I used to call myself a punk
Tory because I had been a Schoolboy when
the Sex Pistols burst onto the scene in
1976 three years later Margaret Thatcher
became prime minister and she was almost
as infuriating to many people as Johnny
Rotten and I loved that I just loved the
fact that the Sex Pistols Shook Up music
and she shook up politics and I arrived
at Oxford in the early 80s at the same
time as my old friend Andrew Sullivan
and we were just odious we were just the
most obnoxious
the most obnoxious young men and we took
pride in in our outrageous
discourse as it would be called today
there was a a famous occasion when
somebody threw a what wasn't famous it
was famous famous to us somebody threw a
party to celebrate the deployment of
Cruz and perishing missiles to Western
Europe and the invitation
was it the neck of a champagne bottle
with a mushroom cloud coming out of it
and that was one of the milder things
that we did so at that time there were
very
limited downside risks to being
obnoxious
and I think that was true in the US too
I said to Peter Thiel the other day you
know you couldn't be you now you know 18
year old Peter Thiel now wouldn't would
be kind of destroyed on the launch pad
whereas you could be as obnoxious as we
were at Oxford at Stanford and and
actually positively benefit from it
there were some risks to going into the
academic profession even then though
because there's a period in your
academic career
even in the 1980s when you're capable of
being destroyed on the launch pad
because you do need people to write
letters of reference and you do need
committees to give you jobs and you need
them also to agree to publish your your
first book all that stuff and so I'll
give you an example of of my risk-averse
behavior I did a lot of Journalism in
the 80s when I was a graduate student I
couldn't have afforded to do a PhD
otherwise because I really had no money
beyond the very meager scholarship and I
was doing research in Germany which was
quite expensive in those days for a
British student
so I did a lot of Journalism but I did
it under assumed names there was a chap
named Alec Campbell there was FF
Gillespie who wrote for punch magazine
and for several years I led a double
life where Neil Ferguson was this
somewhat
right-leaning but terribly rigorous
scholar
but these other
personas would would be writing in even
for the Daily Mail which was a really
scandalous thing for a an aspiring
academic to do and I was outed I can
remember quite early on an old rival of
mine
going around telling everybody that in
fact Alec Campbell was me and those wire
pieces and the Daily Mail were by me and
I was probably who posed for a second he
thought that would kill me and it didn't
what was the blood feud between you and
this arch rival was he hoping to gain
from this or just simply annihilate you
by outing this Scandal of identity flak
jackets that you've been using Maurice
cowling the one of the great
conservative historians of Cambridge
once characterized the the three virtues
in life as irony geniality and Malice
and I think my my contemporary was
motivated by all three it wasn't that he
was
meditating uh career Extinction it was
just a combination of irony geniality
and Malice he presumably was sitting at
high table and there was a lull in the
conversation and he said oh by the way
did you know that that awful Alec
Campbell in the Daily Mail is really
Neil Ferguson and I do remember being
seized by Panic when I realized that
he'd outed me but by that point I think
I'd got far enough
up the lad reached escape velocity on
some level there's another theory about
this which I'll I'll briefly share in
those days you've got to remember that
before the internet communications were
were really quite terrible in the
horizontal domain so you had vertical
communication you could listen to the
BBC
if they didn't ban you're single you
could you could do that but Oxford and
Cambridge didn't communicate very much
and so you could be outed in Oxford but
but still get a job in Cambridge because
the news had not in fact traveled across
the country in the same way that my
mentor Norman Stone got a job in Oxford
despite having behaved quite
outrageously in Cambridge but but his
his Cambridge backers were really trying
to export him to Oxford so they perjured
themselves in their letters of reference
and knowing and Oxford really bothered
to pick up a phone and say is any of
this true so I think what really
happened was that I was outed in Oxford
but in the nick of time got a job in
Cambridge and was able to start a new
life with a clean sheet so I'm gonna
make a confession as a knuckle dragging
long Islander I don't actually know what
high table is or the high table I can
imagine in my mind some British High
Society function
maybe with with some fantastic adult
beverages but what what is this what
what image should high table conjure in
my mind well you're right about the
beverages
you've watched some Harry Potter movies
I have yes that's all you need to know
so it's basically the the case that that
Hogwarts is a sort of entertaining
amalgam of of eaten and an Oxford
College quite a lot of it's actually
shot at Christchurch and you'll remember
that when they have their their
spectacular Feasts the teachers sit on a
slightly elevated dice with a big long
table
and not Gandalf wrong wizard he does
look like Gandalf
I kept my dumbled or I get my children's
fiction confused because I have to watch
so much of it
Dumbledore gives his speeches from from
that high table and if you go to to
dinner at Christchurch essentially you
will see a version of Hogwarts slightly
less visually striking but this same
basic idea and the thing that's
attractive about boxing Cambridge if you
come from Glasgow remember I you think
Long Island is
low let me tell you about Glasgow so I
came from what was once one of the great
industrial metropols of the British
Empire but by the 1970s was Rust Belt we
were doing hillbilly elegy before DD
Vance was even born I think and it was a
quite a messy place and Oxford by
comparison just looked like a really
high-end BBC costume drama in which the
men wore Tweed suits and they dined at
high table and at high table the most
delicious wines were served and all of
this was irresistibly attractive to me
when I was a teenager I thought I got
I've got to get out of Glasgow and I'm
going to have a study like that and I'm
going to eat at high table and wear and
wear a tweet suit and I did those things
and it was great
was it did it live up to the dreams what
did you like about it in those days when
I made it first a high table it was in
Cambridge
and I was at a college crisis college
that had been immortalized in a novel
The Masters by CP snow in which
Cambridge politics provides
the drama and academic politics has its
own peculiar appeal as Henry Kissinger
famously said it's so poisonous because
the stakes are so low very good line now
you are actually of good authority to
say did Kissinger also say I left
academics because I couldn't stand the
politics something along those lines or
is that just one of those attributed to
Abraham Lincoln or Oscar Wilde quotes
floating around on the internet
I mean Kissinger said so many things
that you you deny he said something and
the next day you find it in in one of
the documents so he probably said that
but it's certainly fits but I I um I got
to Christ's and and there were in fact
three Masters two former Masters and one
current serving Master regularly dining
at high table and the vicious way in
which the four Masters undermined the
serving master was a my introduction to
academic politics luckily one of the
former Masters was Sir John Plum Jack
Plum a very influential historian of
that generation he had
come from Humble origins in the town of
Leicester but had risen through the
academic ranks had been involved lechley
Park during the war had got to know the
Rothschild family and had been
introduced to the the lights of Chateau
Lafitte by the Rothschilds and he used
to serve Chateau La feet at special
occasions this is a nice wine I assume
it was one of the great bordeaux's oh my
goodness of course unavailable in Long
Island and in Glasgow but available in
Cambridge and so I I fell in with him
and uh you know he would he would on his
you know 85th birthday serve some
fantastic
vintage and the younger Dons you know
the engineering fellows would sort of
take a couple of sips and then and then
leave most of it undrunk and go back to
their Laboratories and this would send
Jack into a rage
he was a very cantankerous old man and I
as the junior most fellow I remember one
on one occasion I was such a Shameless
sycophant
but also with a taste for Chateau lefeed
I said after they'd all gone I said Jack
it's a terrible shame to to waste this
wine I'll I'm going to drink the dregs
from the glasses that they've left and
he loved me for that and I also you know
I lived to tell the tale none of them
had any obviously lethal infectious
diseases and it's the most wonderful
wine and once you've drunk lefeed it's
hard to go back to what you were
drinking before you're spoiled spoiled
for life that scene should make it into
a screenplay at the turn of some ACT I
mean that is a fantastic scene may I may
I drink the dregs
would it please you if I if I were to
drink the drugs it was a good move
because Jack Plum was one of the great
academic patrons Simon Sharma was was
one of Jack's Protege and Linda collion
and so by sucking up to Jack I did my
career no harm at all because when Jack
wrote a reference when he wrote a letter
of reference he would begin not since
Edward Gibbon has an historian written
uh this level of quality wildly
hyperbolic references wow so yeah you
know academic politics involves
that kind of
that kind of odious behavior and I'm
afraid I was capable of it in my in my
20s still am still skilled one might say
so let's come back to a ajp Taylor a
number of questions about ajp Taylor I
had never heard this name I'm ashamed to
admit until doing some research for this
conversation
and
number of questions again with the
Baseline of of Long Island kept in mind
because these are probably going to be
fairly 101 questions one is
how should people think about defining
philosophy of History
that's number one
and number two
is
the Taylor line related to historical
sensibility being similar to musical
Sensibility
and if you could just say more about
that
the philosophy of history is barely
studied
or indeed told and yet you can't really
be an historian without a philosophy of
History you have to understand the
nature of causation these days nobody
bothers with that which is why a lot of
academic history is garbage
I became fascinated by the philosophy of
History
at that time when I was drinking chateau
lefeed with Jack Plum and realized that
there was a very Central problem namely
that any causal statement this is
obvious to philosophers and it's obvious
to people who do the law implies are
counterfactual in other words if we say
that the conversation between Tim
Ferriss and Neil Ferguson in November
2022 led to the outbreak of War
between China and the United States the
following year
that implies that if we hadn't had the
conversation the war wouldn't have
happened and so the what if question
what if they hadn't had the conversation
is a legitimate question in the same way
if you think that Hitler was the key
architect of World War II and it
wouldn't have happened without him then
it's legitimate to ask what would have
happened if Hitler had in fact been
assassinated prior to September 1939. so
those what-if questions were of great
importance to me as a young scholar and
teacher that was how I used to teach
students I would say well what if what
if that hadn't happened what if Britain
hadn't intervened in 1914
Taylor was a historian who was
sympathetic to that approach
his view was a somewhat
skeptical ironical view that men only
learn from history how to make new
mistakes and his books are shot through
with the the role of contingency
one of the things that made Taylor
attractive to me in parentheses Was His
Brilliant prose style up there with
George Orwell as one of the master
stylists of the 20th century and a
tremendous master of paradox
enough one-liners to the line about the
1848 revolutions as being the the
turning point when Germany failed to
turn all that stuff I found exciting
because
being able to write like that is also
the way to convince a reader to be able
to talk like that is to convince an
audience so that's how the philosophy of
History relates to the style of of
History
the second question
that you asked about music his his
assertion that that the historical
sensibility is a bit like the uh
receptiveness to music is is Right
history is not a science it can't be a
science because we can't re-run events
and laboratory and see if consistently
War breaks out in 1939 with or without
Hitler
so what we're doing when we study the
past as a great Oxford philosopher of
History RG Collingwood said is we're
kind of reconstituting past Human
Experience from the bits and pieces that
have been left behind and as we do that
it's a very subtle process of of mental
reenactment of experience and I'm not
sure that Taylor was wrong to compare it
to that that musical side of of the
human psyche interestingly someone else
said much the same thing a man named
Fritz Kramer who was Henry Kissinger's
great mentor during and after World War
II and Kramer said that that Kissinger
had this kind of sensibility uh he was
attuned to history I I think that's a
very very right
you've got to have
the ear for it and it's quite obvious
when one reads a book when a historian's
tone deaf and shouldn't really have gone
into the business just as it would be
obvious if they tried to conduct an
orchestra or play a concerto so yeah I
think it's much closer to music than it
is to science how does that show up for
you having a trained ear
in historical resonance let's just say
the ear for history how does that show
up when it when it is
part of an author's Constitution or
developed repertoire what does it look
like in their writing or their thinking
when I was writing the history of the
Rothschild Banks and family back in the
1990s
I spend a lot of my time reading through
Dusty old letters and
diary entries and
minutes of meetings
and the most striking documents were the
letters that the the Rothschild Brothers
wrote to one another there were five of
them they'd come out of the Frankfurt
ghetto
they had built within an amazingly short
time the most powerful financial
institution in Europe already by the
1820s and they wrote almost daily to one
another because they no longer lived
together one was in London one was in
Paris one was in Vienna one was in in
Naples
and one was in Frankfurt so these
letters were almost more like phone
calls
and uh and they were extremely hard to
decipher because they wrote in Hebrew
characters
which which were extremely difficult to
read even if you knew Hebrew
the only way I could access the letters
was to have a scholar who could read
them a wonderful man named Mordecai
Zucker read them aloud onto audio
cassettes and so I spent a lot of time
listening to these letters
and when he read them aloud they were
mostly German with occasional Hebrew
words
they were electrifying documents they
they cast an entirely new light on the
19th century and
they were entirely absorbing uh not
least because they were so regular so it
was very high frequency correspondence
and I can remember one letter and I'll
never forget the experience of hearing
it
in which the eldest of the brothers
whose name was amshul described what it
was like for the first time to own land
he owned a guy he bought a garden
on the outskirts of of Frankfurt prior
to that
Jews have not been allowed to own real
estate
and he
as a result of the upheavals caused by
the French Revolution suddenly was able
to do that and he writes to the the
brothers saying I bought the garden and
last night I slept in it I slept outside
in the garden
and he described the feeling and I
remember
and it still makes my spine tingle the
feeling of
excitement that this quite dry man
because he was uh almost had had the
mentality of the accountant amongst the
brothers but this quite dry man had done
that he'd slept Outdoors for the first
time in a garden that he owned
and I I was moved to tears and I thought
what is this like why is this such a
moving document
and I remembered the moment in
Beethoven's Fidelio when the prisoners
are let out into the open air he
actually uses the the expression
free air
and that prisoner's chorus when they
sing what it is to be in the open air
struck me as exactly the the appropriate
music for that moment and I remember
pushing it on
my then
stereo player and listening to Beethoven
and listening again to the letter and
thinking this is an enormously important
document which captures what
emancipation means what it is to be
suddenly given a civil right that you've
previously been denied and often in my
my career I've I've had these epiphanies
moments when a document suddenly
reveals something profound and and often
that that moment of connection has a has
a musical Dimension to it the best
historians have that ability to bring
the experiences of the Dead Alive bring
them back to life make you
empathize with them despite the distance
and time and and space and an experience
and that that's a hard thing to do and
not not many people can do it well
indeed many historians these days don't
even try because they don't feel that
our mission is to reconstitute past
experience they feel that our mission is
to go back and judge people in the past
for their their sins by by our standards
and that means that there's a project
which I think is very hostile to
historical understanding to
to change the mission of the historian
instead of trying to re-constitute past
experience we're really just sitting
there passing judgments on past actions
I'm very against that I think it
produces very bad history it also
produces quite boring history
so if we go back to AGP what did the ajp
stand for actually I should know that
Alan Taylor I forget one probably John
Percival but I might be wrong but he was
known as Alan to his Intimates but in
those days people quite often published
with only their initials it created
perhaps a certain distance between the
author and the the public I never
contemplated being NC Ferguson though
it's just too off-putting isn't it
non-commissioned officer Ferguson I do
like it though so Dr Taylor
said as you mentioned men only learn
from history how to make new mistakes
now he seems I don't know this person at
all but
as you describe being a master Paradox
also being a Wordsmith and gifted in
that particular way that there may be
some truth in this statement but he also
dedicated his life to history so if
you've got a few drinks
a few few glasses of Chateau Lafitte
into Dr Taylor and said all right all
right I like I know that's a great line
but like why is history important to you
why do you why have you dedicated your
life to this
how do you think you might answer that
I'm pretty sure he was Mr Taylor in
those days people didn't bother getting
doctorates I'm using Dr Moore in the Dr
Seuss capacity
the English regarded uh doctorates as a
German invention that
didn't need to Sully one's life with a
Mr Taylor perhaps wisely
Taylor's
conviction was that
most people thought wrongly about the
past had misconceptions about it and
these misconceptions LED them into into
error
so one of the most controversial books
he ever wrote was a book on the origins
of the second World War
in which he argued
very
paradoxically as a as a contrarian that
really Hitler had not been particularly
unusual German leader and that Hitler's
foreign policy had in some ways been the
continuation of previous foreign
policies and that the war was really the
fault of the blundering incompetence in
London and Paris who had made the policy
of appeasement and had pursued it very
ineptly
the book is still worth reading even
although these days most people would
disagree with Taylor because they would
argue as I would argue that that Hitler
was a kind of monster who's whose
ideology and whose personality were very
unusual and a departure uh from German
Tradition at any event the book is
brilliant and it's designed to force you
to reassess your assumptions about why
World War II happened
I'm motivated by the same belief that
most people think wrong things about the
past and base their actions on these
erroneous assumptions
and the job of the historian is to
challenge the conventional wisdom about
past events in the belief that the
conventional wisdom is actually quite a
dangerous
thing
so it's it's to me uninteresting to
write a book that essentially repeats
the arguments that have been made before
I have no motivation to write a book
unless it's challenging what people have
thought about the past whether it's the
origins of the first world war which I
wrote a book about whether it's the
nature of 20th century conflict whether
it's the history of money whatever it is
I'm motivated to say something that
challenges received opinion in the
belief that by doing that I might
possibly improve decision making in the
present and and future I believe and
I've always believed that we are trying
to learn lessons from the past and when
Taylor said that men only learn from the
past how to make new mistakes he wasn't
dismissing the possibility of learning
from history but he was being ironical
it's probably right that no matter how
hard we try we'll end up making new
mistakes but that's not a council of
Despair and I I passionately believe
that the study of history must be
motivated by a desire to do better or at
least to fail better next time so that I
think is what you'd have got from Taylor
if you'd plied him with Chateau laffy
although Taylor would he would have
resisted
your very American impulse to get a
sincere
answer
and I'm enough of an American now to
give sincere answers but the typical
British dawn of Taylor's generation
would have just they would he would not
have been able to resist the temptation
to tease you yeah
maybe I need more of that maybe I should
spend more time at the high table yeah
you have given me an appetite for some
tweet I will be honest it's good in
Winter the thing about Tweed is it's
there for places where there's no
Central Heating and and these Oxford
colleges they're buildings often date
back to to before the Reformation
it wasn't as if england was famous for
its central heating even in the 20th
century and so to understand the Tweed
suit is a phenomenon you have to
remember these studies are pretty cold
even if you've got a fire in the great
now that we're heading towards another
energy crisis I believe the Tweed suit
will recover maybe not in the United
States but in in England pretty soon
there's going to be a run on Tweed suits
you heard it here first folks Alpha and
Neil Ferguson is long tweeted
a few just uh miscellaneous Mordecai
incredible name always one of my
favorites you mentioned Percival that
may not have been the the P of the ajp
but also a fantastic name could you say
a bit more about the role of contingency
the I guess for the through line
one of the through lines of Taylor's
writing and
you can answer these out of order of
course
for someone who wanted to get a good
taste of his writing because your
description of paradox and the use of
paradox and Powerful metaphor and prose
is really appealing to me
where would you suggest someone start or
where would you suggest perhaps I start
well I'll give you a couple of
examples of historical contingency
first
the decision
for war
in 1914
was taken in Britain
on a weekend
which was an unusual time for the
British cabinet to meet
and when they went into the meeting
I think it's fair to say that nobody
really knew how it would turn out
in particular the then Chancellor of the
exchequer David Lloyd George was
expected to be against intervention
because he had been a man of the left
and it was not obvious that that
intervening in the war was a
particularly left liberal thing to do
there were plenty of people in the in
the cabinet who had deep reservations
about about intervening in the war and
it was seen as something that the the
conservatives were much more
enthusiastic
4. and so people expected Lloyd George
to speak up against intervention he'd
already given indications prior to
August II that he had doubts about the
wisdom of action
but he didn't
even although he was handed a note by
one of his cabinet colleagues
encouraging him to speak up
he had decided that it would ultimately
be better for David Lloyd George if
Britain went to war and he was right
because he ended up becoming prime
minister during the war because Herbert
Asquith had descended into a kind of
alcoholic fog
that's a good example of how one
individual's
action or lack of action can have very
profound consequences and I wrote a lot
about that in the pity of war and and in
in the book virtual history because I
I think it's important
for people to understand that while
there are great historical forces at
work there were powerful forces driving
Europe towards conflict prior to 1914.
there is a very important role for
contingency and that continues to be
true today and once you think about the
historical process in in a similar way
let me give you a contemporary example
and uh so in terms of contingency just
the use of that word I think of
contingency in the context of say
contingency plan in this case do you
mean it's it's sort of a a split test
with an alternate version of historical
reality where someone did or did not do
something did or did not play a part in
a given conversation is that what you
mean by contingency contingency here
means a relatively small event or
decision and it doesn't need to be a
decision it can be something accidental
has very major consequences
and historical causations like that
something relatively small can have
tremendous ramifications I'll give you
another illustration
this year
most people including the US government
thought that if Russia invaded Ukraine
the Ukrainian government would quite
quickly fold and it was assumed that
Vladimir zielinski the Ukrainian
president would bail
he didn't
he gave his famous response I don't want
an air ticket I want ammunition
and zelenski's courage when they were
closing in a cave with a high
probability that they would assassinate
the Russians
turned the
the course of history
in a way that I think is is now quite
widely understood people know zelenski
is an important historical figure he
gets a lot of attention because he is
charismatic figure who understands how
to how to use modern media to to
communicate with an audience that's
that's the benefit of having a very
seasoned Entertainer as your president
but I think what's really important
there is that his courage particularly
the famous uh video selfie video where
he says I'm here the defense minister is
here we're here they're standing in the
streets of Kiev the Russians are closing
in at that point on the capital that was
a tremendous
a tremendous Act of Courage but he
emboldened ordinary ukrainians not to
fold and it also intimidated the
collaborators who were ready to help the
Russians not to act so the contingency
there is
zelensi had gone according to our
expectation and taken the plane
then Putin would have had cave within a
matter of days or weeks and the war
would be over
so I think one of the things that's
exciting about the study of history is
you're trying to remind yourself again
and again that what happened that what
we know happened might have gone the
other way that the Cuban Missile Crisis
ended in both sides essentially backing
down was not predetermined there was a
moment when a Soviet submarine Commander
gave the order to fire a nuclear tip
torpedo at U.S naval surface ships
so we came within a hair spread of World
War III
these alternate worlds these histories
that didn't happen have to be alive in
your mind when you're writing history
the Fatal mistake is to write history as
if it was bound to happen the way it
happened
and this of course is the mistake that a
great majority of historians make
forgetting that we don't know at the
time at the moment we didn't know the
morning of
the 24th of February that that zelenski
would stand his ground
nobody knew that I wonder if even
zielinski at that moment knew what it
was that he was going to do so
I say all this because like it's really
important to to convey to your listeners
and viewers how exciting history is and
how studying it makes you understand the
course of events in your own life better
removes that passivity that sometimes
people succumb to if you think great
historical forces are going to have
inevitable outcomes if you have a
deterministic view of the historical
process it's very easy to lapse into
fatalism yeah absolutely there's the
other trap which is the conspiracy
theories well you know the truth of the
matter is that actually Soros and the
Rothschilds are orchestrating all this
again you you you throw up your hands
and you abandon the attempt to
understand how the historical process
works okay what should one read to get a
flavor of Alan Taylor's extraordinary
Talent he's a very good short-term
memory by the way you're a very good
character Mary do my best please
continue
Taylor's Masterpiece is quite a dense
read and I wouldn't recommend it the
struggle for Mastery in Europe that
that's the book I most admire but it's
probably the last thing to to start with
the Widowmaker yeah I mean I love the
book but I'm a little idiosyncratic I
like long and
dense books but
the essays that he wrote
which were often book reviews
are available in paperback collections
in the in the old days they used to
publish the esses of historians I wish
they still did because I would have many
more books to my credit if I could just
repackage my essays as books but his
books of s's are really worth reading in
the same way that if you want to get to
Orwell
don't just read Animal Farm in 1984 Rita
Orwell's amazing essays there are four
fantastic volumes of Orwell's essays and
uh he and Taylor between them were just
such masters of short form English prose
you will just feel like you're you're
eating Turkish delight as you read your
way through their essays
in the vein of adding to your tally of
books published if if the book doesn't
exist with the title The histories that
didn't happen just saying has a nice
ring to it a bit of alliteration easy to
grasp not too abstract in any case Lewis
namier was a great Cambridge historian
who said that the key to history was
having a sense of what didn't happen and
I always think of Thelonious Monk's line
about jazz it's it's the notes you don't
play
and as a jazz fan I think history has to
have that kind of Thelonious Monk feel
to it where you're kind of telling the
reader this didn't happen but it it
nearly did and people at the time
thought about it this is the key rule by
the way you can't just fantasize and
devise counterfactuals that are entirely
out of your imagination you have to go
with things that people at the time
thought might happen that's a really
important guard rail on counterfactual
History the fancy term for what if
history or histories that didn't happen
is is counter factual history and I'm a
passionate believer in it and I'm proud
to say that
despite my making the argument for
counterfactual history back in the 1990s
that's a long time ago now it's still
Counter Culture it is still what the
cool kids do in history and the
establishment still looks down on it I
used to be annoyed about that I used to
think why don't they understand why do
these people not see you have to talk
about what didn't happen and now I'm
glad that it's still cool and minority
and you know kind of underground that's
that's fine with me you established
historians carry on doing what you're
doing you carry on saying we're only
here to study what did happen you carry
on doing that but just know that the
cool kids have seen through this and
they know that it's it's really BS you
have to talk about what didn't happen to
understand what did happen obviously or
all the things that so nearly didn't
happen and I'm no historian I I make no
claims otherwise don't play one on the
internet however
I did listen don't know how you feel
about this podcast but I I have enjoyed
many episodes of Hardcore History by Dan
Carlin who would not call himself a
historian either but he did an episode
on the assassination of Franz Ferdinand
and everything that came of that and
when you dig into the specifics I mean
it is just mind-boggling to think how
that
came about and how many near-misses
it's it's it's it just boggles the mind
to think
how as you put if you zoom too far out
and just view history as these
inevitable tectonic plates
then there's a fatalism that can set in
and you throw up your hands and you know
move on to just staring at Tick Tock all
day or whatever you might do you know at
the same time if you bleed into the
conspiracy theory side of things same
outcome
but I need to do more reading by the way
John Colin is great okay Dan Collin is
great I love what he does I haven't
heard that particular episode but doing
anything that gets a wider audience for
history is is good and I recently heard
his great interview with Elon Musk about
about the technology of of World War II
it's brilliant and it's brilliant partly
because Elon knows a lot about
the hardware of of World War II and so
you think of World War II it's kind of
an engineering problem in the end it's
like who can build better planes better
tanks all that stuff but Colin's doing
terrific work and uh yeah you're right
1914 is a perfect illustration because
princip the Assassin totally fails the
first time and how many assassins get a
second chance because the driver of the
target takes the wrong turning and then
he stops right next to the bar where
you're getting hammered because you
failed your first attempt or whatever
the story is it's crazy uh
are there any other examples of
Correspondence that you have been taken
by not necessarily in the same way but
in a similar way to the exchanges
between the Rothschilds and the reason I
ask is
I have had I consume a lot of
biographies I do read a fair amount of
history but I don't really know how to
assess historians and I I wish that I
had a way of establishing the biases up
front because we are all human
subjective there must be biases I'd
imagine so much like a conflict of
interest or special interest section in
a scientific paper like okay at least we
know like what chips these people have
on the board
so I have defaulted to looking for
correspondence that was never intended
for publication as a way to get a a view
into the thinking of the time what was
happening at the time are there any
other examples that pop up when I I use
the prompt correspondence
absolutely
possible it's attractive about
historical study is reading the letters
and and Diaries of of the dead or very
very old and the non-published material
if you inhabit the world of the
published which many historians do that
is to say they essentially write their
books on the basis of things that have
been published whether it's books or
articles you are
really doing research
at one remove from reality I've written
books like that and there is a role for
them because you're you're really
synthesizing the scholarship of of many
many authors and trying to produce a
single single
distilled version of of what happened
but there's a difference between writing
a book based on published material and
writing a book based on unpublished
material and it's a huge difference I
attach much more importance to books
that I've written based on unpublished
material and books that others have
written
why because that which is published is
is essentially filtered a huge filter
has determined what sees the light of
day in print when you enter an archive
the only filter is that nobody destroyed
it
and somebody thought to preserve it in
at least enough of an orderly form that
you can look at it and this is a
radically different world that you enter
it's not a perfect representation of
reality but it's a lot closer to reality
than the published material
and so let me illustrate the point as I
write the biography of of Henry
Kissinger the first volume of which came
out a few years ago I'm writing the
second volume now
there is of course a very well
established narrative about the Vietnam
War about the Cold War about the opening
to China about the Middle East it's all
very well established there are lots of
of books out there about it
but when you when you enter the realm of
the the unpublished correspondence
including transcripts of telephone calls
even the tapes of telephone calls which
were certainly not supposed to see the
light of day
because the Nixon Administration is the
best documented administration of all
time thanks to Nixon's ultimately fatal
error of taping everything
the world is is a very different one
from that that world that you thought
you understood thanks to Christopher
Hitchens I mean Christopher hitchens's
book on Kissinger has sold many copies
it contains I think from memory 12
footnotes it refers to that many sources
it is a work of Journalism
of outrageous superficiality it's a
polemical Hatchet job and it shouldn't
be treated as history hitch was a friend
of mine I miss him but it's not it's
important to recognize that that's not a
work of history really
another way of thinking about this is
what's the ratio of words read to words
written now I wished him that that ratio
was published on the front of books this
is a one-to-one book like he read
basically one word for every word that
he wrote and this is a hundred to one
book and this is a thousand to one book
and thousand to one it seems like it's
about right I mean most most books are
really not worth reading because they
are
their ratio is close to Unity there may
even be books where the ratio is below
University that they've written actually
more words than they read and preparing
to write the book sounds like the
internet in a nutshell yeah yeah right I
mean that's the Blogger spheres like why
bother doing research I have a great
opinion
so I'm I'm a very much a thousand to one
kind of person I like
to dig and deeply and and broadly and
and to enter that Realm of the
unpublished and I'm insatiable as I
enter it I I can never be entirely
satisfied I'm reconstructing Kissinger's
life almost on an hour-by-hour basis to
try to see a new way of thinking about
the 1970s which was a pivotal decade in
a way many ways to rethink that decade
is is my current mission
and of course I won't succeed in
changing that many people's minds
because most people made up their minds
about Henry Kissinger long ago in about
I don't know 1974.
but but I do think we have to rethink
the Cold War
as a matter of urgency because we're in
one we're in a new Cold War in Cold War
II and if we don't think long and hard
about what went right and what went
wrong in Cold War one there is a high
probability that we're going to repeat
some uh some pretty serious mistakes
so let's talk about Cold War II I was
actually going to segue to
your thinking and observations of
the not mutually exclusive
combination of maybe conditions that
have been set over the last five to ten
or more years that are now
leading to
certain types of inertia in terms of
Trends converging trends that may or may
not be avoidable then there's a lot of
wiggle room with independent actors and
and so on as we've discussed but
I've I've already described Cold War II
I believe correct me if I'm wrong as uh
China senior partner Russia Junior
partner right in contrast to Cold War
one if you were
placing bets on likely
events or developments over the the next
handful of years
what would you put out as perhaps some
reasonably probable scenarios that we'll
see develop
the cliche quotes often ascribe to Mark
Twain is that history doesn't repeat
itself but it Rhymes but he never said
that
Twain never used those words that's a
made-up quote what Twain actually said
back in the 1870s was that
his true is a bit like a kaleidoscope
and as you turned it
certain patterns could repeat themselves
so let's think about this as a
kaleidoscope you'll remember those
things we had as kids where you kind of
stick out your eyes like that's
psychedelic what happens if I turn oh
that's also psychedelic but different
Cold War One
had certain common features with Cold
War II and and there were certain very
important differences so we shouldn't
expect things to play out exactly the
same
on the other hand it's clear that we
have an ideological rivalry between the
United States and the People's Republic
of China there is clearly a
technological race going on
there is also a geopolitical dimension
to this conventional territorial
Dimension and and this is a point Graham
Allison made in his book destined for
war there's some probability that they
end up in a hot War because what's a
cold war George Orwell coined the phrase
to to mean a piece that is no peace it
is something that has latent the
possibility of an actual Hot War and I
think the United States and China have
been in this kind of cold war situation
for at least four years maybe longer
that the Chinese would probably say
longer but we didn't notice we didn't
notice the beginning of Cold War one
either
when Orwell talks about Cold War in 1945
and Churchill in 1946 talked about an
iron curtain most Americans were no no
no the Stalin's been our Ally in World
War II
you're just warmongering and um it took
until 1950 when there was a hot war in
Korea for most Americans to say ah maybe
they're right I mean Canon wasn't
immediately hailed as a prophet when he
talks about containment
the thing about cold Wars is that by and
large people in the west don't really
notice their beginning and take a while
to understand the scale of the challenge
so we're at that early Cold War stage I
think that's a good analogy that works
well and also this war in Ukraine is
like the Korean War it's the first Hot
War of Cold War II and it makes you kind
of get that you're in a cold war
as in Cold War One the hot War happens
in a slightly unexpected location the
hot war that kicked off Cold War one was
Korea
and the US hadn't really been paying
very close attention to Korea when that
that kicked off
so if you take this kind of approach and
recognize that there are similarities
except that instead of a nuclear arms
race we're in an AI race and a Quantum
Computing race
if you recognize the difference which is
there's much more economic
interpenetration between the US and
China than the ever Wars between the US
and the Soviet Union
you're then in a position to start
hazarding guesses about what happens
next
which is what you asked me to do and
these are are very difficult things to
get right and and I often think that if
one makes a right prediction it's more
luck that it turns out to be right than
judgment because this is a complex
system of enormous complexity
so when we try to say anything about
global politics we're we're really
engaged in in an exercise beyond our
human brains but let me have a go
right now the US and China are on
collision course over Taiwan and Taiwan
is to This Cold War what Cuba was to the
last Cold War it's the flash point it's
an island in close proximity to one of
the players then it was close to the U.S
this time it's close to China
it's an island which seems to be worth
more than its territorial size would
suggest actually taiwan's more important
than Cuba ever was because Taiwan is
where 92 percent of the most
sophisticated semiconductors in the
world are manufactured by tsmc
and so in some ways the potential for a
crisis over Taiwan is higher than the
potential ever was for a crisis over
Cuba so I think what happens next is
that we end up with a showdown over over
Taiwan at some point in the next few
years could be in 2024 when there's an
election scheduled in Taiwan
and it would also make sense to do it
then from a Chinese point of view
because who knows who will be president
in 2025 but probably not somebody as
completely
incompetent as Joe Biden so my sense is
that the crisis is not far away even
although the Chinese don't look terribly
ready for a full-blown Invasion and
that's the thing that that I'll be
watching most closely in the coming
years the other thing to remember is and
this again is is in the nature of a
guess that
a characteristic feature of Cold War one
was that crises would happen in multiple
locations at roughly the same kind of
time so the Middle East always mattered
and it was the place where things would
periodically blow up I think the Middle
East is about to blow up again
because the Iranian regime clearly has
an incentive to get into a war because
when it's at War it can slaughter a
domestic opposition with much greater
ease so I'm afraid that we're probably
going to see a middle eastern crisis
even before Taiwan blows up and what
worries me the most Tim is that the
lesson of Cold War one is that we only
narrowly avoided World War III as I said
already
so if we're in this kind of a scenario
where there are crises in Eastern Europe
potentially in the Middle East
potentially in the Far East
I think just keeping this a cold war
will be quite a challenge that will be a
good outcome if we just say hmm that was
Cold War II and it'll be a great outcome
if it ends the same way as Cold War one
with peaceful victory for the west but
there is no guarantee at this point that
Cold War II stays cold and there is no
guarantee at this point that the United
States and its Allies win and that's the
real lesson of Cold War one it was not
inevitable that it stayed cold and it
was not inevitable that we won
so to follow up on a few things that you
mentioned and as background
I was an East Asian Studies major at
Princeton spent 96 part of 96 about six
months studying at two universities in
Beijing so I was able to see the the
bicycles Beijing
prior to the Audi and BMW Beijing that
we see today but the reason I mentioned
that is that I then subsequently
traveled quite a lot in South America
and a fair amount in Africa and I was
able to see
quite obviously the
extensive infrastructure that was being
built
by Chinese companies also seemingly
often with governmental Chinese
governmental support
and
from a geopolitical natural resource and
resource distribution perspective
this is not my area of expertise but it
seems like China has been playing
three-dimensional chess for a while now
with with respect to all of that as you
mentioned Taiwan is strategically from a
technological manufacturing perspective
and non-trivial compared to say Cuba
and my question is what can the U.S do
or is it a a day late and a dollar short
I don't want to make it too
fatalistic but
for the US to
be prepared or prepare itself and not
just be pseudo-prepared which we have
been for many things in the last several
years
what can be done what would you suggest
or your writer points out that this is a
global challenge that China's Focus not
only on on Taiwan or for that matter the
South China Sea on its own
neighborhood it has been pursuing an
ambitious and quite heterogeneous Global
strategy
since Xi Jinping came to par and
the Belton Road initiative is is only
part of that there are all kinds of
other things digital Silk Road the
export of surveillance technology to
governments in the developing World
investment in lots of technology
companies in Emerging Markets
you can see the infrastructure when you
go to Africa
even 10 years ago when I made a
documentary about this for British
television
place like Zambia had really quite
extraordinary and visible Chinese
presence not only in football stadiums
and highways but also in
in mining and agriculture so there is no
question that we confront a a new kind
of Chinese challenge because
there really hasn't been an era until
now when China was so clearly pursuing
a global strategy and by the way that
strategy was copied from the West there
was a conscious decision by Chinese
leaders to learn from Western history
and to try and adopt some of the things
that we had done that Chinese Empires
hadn't done really hadn't even
contemplated doing since all the way
back in the 15th century so
this hybrid China which simultaneously
has continuities from Chinese imperial
history from The Mao era is also a China
doing things that China hasn't done in
the past
I think the United States has adopted
recently a strategy of technological
containment
that's most obvious in the recent
restrictions imposed by the Commerce
Department that are designed to prevent
China advancing technologically by
denying it access to the most
sophisticated semiconductors and the
equipment you need to make them
so our strategy is to try to freeze
China's technological advance
seems hard to do right so on the one
side it's extremely hard to build tsmc
in mainland China and I think there's
some reason to believe they can't
but the idea that you can just sort of
use economic sanctions to keep your
principal adversary permanently behind
you technologically to me historically
seems like a stretch and would seem also
to me to raise the incentives
to take Taiwan
because if he can't access the tsmc
products then he can either try and get
control of tsmc but if he fails and we
blow it up or they blow it up then he's
no worse off but we're a lot worse off
so I think there are downside risks to
our strategy of technological
containment that aren't being given
enough attention broadly speaking I
think a regime like China's is at its
most dangerous when it starts to feel
that it's strategic options are
narrowing and that there may in fact be
only a small window of opportunity to
bid for Primacy or at least parity with
the dominant superpower we could do an
awful lot more
creative things than we're doing in
developing countries
that is to say we could compete much
better in Africa
but the problem is when we go to Africa
we come bearing Aid it usually has lots
of strings attached to it when the
Chinese show up there are not many
strings and it's not Aid it's investment
to put it very simply so we're not
really offering a particularly
attractive alternative a concrete
example of this is when we decided that
it would be a bad idea for Huawei to
supply the world's 5G networks we went
around telling everybody Huawei very bad
but we didn't have a better
alternative as my friend one of my
African friends complains that you come
and tell us not to to buy Huawei we
listen and then we say so what should we
buy and it's like oh we don't know or
try Ericsson it's way more expensive and
they won't give you any credit but try I
mean that that's that's stupid so we
can't expect to win Cold War II if we
have no better product at least when the
Soviets were going around Africa saying
you know we'll we'll give you the
planned economy we had a better idea we
definitely had a better pitch than the
planned economy so I think that's that's
what concerns me is that our our
strategy in Cold War II at this point
looks very risky and quite likely to
fail and that's because when you read
the most recent National Security
strategy document we write things like
we don't want to have a cold war this is
not a cold war
um and then we go right ahead and list
all the things that we're doing that
makes it very clear that we are in a
cold war
that's cognitive dissonance it's like
the news that I see every day now just
like it we may you know so and so says
we may be entering a recession in six to
12 months I'm like am I seeing a
different version of reality here
thou doth protests too much the
cognitive dissonance is painful to
manage whether you're talking about the
economy or about our foreign policy so
yeah I mean that's kind of what I'm
thinking a lot about and I do it
tentatively because
things could change direction
in an unexpected way
American politics is always a bit of a
wild card but it's pretty clear that the
pendulum is swinging to the right
that means that there's a pretty high
probability of a Republican president
by January 2025 and who knows
if Donald Trump is re-elected
he could call off Cold War II in an
afternoon he could fly to Beijing
do the best deal such a great deal with
my good friend XI jinpingling that could
happen and most people struggle a little
bit with that that part of thinking
about history because could you say a
bit more about that why would it be so
easy
that's what he would have done if he'd
been re-elected Trump doesn't want to be
in Cold War II he thinks it's stupid he
just wanted to do trade war and what's
funny about the Trump Administration was
that Trump kind of turns everybody's
attention to China wins the argument
convinces everybody China's a major
threat but all he really wanted to do
was a trade war with tariffs and the
point of the tariffs was going to beat
China up and then he was going to go to
Beijing and do a great deal that was the
plan there was going to be a photo op
and of course he didn't win and so that
didn't happen and ironically the Biden
Administration has been more hawkish on
China than the Trump Administration was
and that's also a product of American
politics because at some point in 2020
Biden's handlers said to him you can't
win unless you're as hawkish on China As
Trump and maybe more hawkish and so
Biden who'd in fact been anything but
hawkish during his time as vice
president on the campaign Trail started
to beat up on China and then they got
stuck with this hawkish policy which is
now dominating their whole strategy so I
think it's important to recognize that
Trump's foreign policy however you think
about Trump however much you hate Trump
and many people listening to this will
have
major reasons for hating trumpet the
foreign policy objectivity was quite
successful
and it was quite successful
without risking conflict Trump was not
somebody who wanted actual War he just
wanted trade War and the trade war was
always intended to be a temporary
measure you were imposing the tariffs
and they were going to go to China and
say well we'll take the tariffs off if
you do this so I I can imagine a
scenario where quite easily can imagine
a scenario where Trump gets reelected
and does that and at that point you know
Cold War II would at least temporarily
be in some kind of
suspension so I'd love for you to poke
holes in a bunch of things I'm gonna I'm
gonna say because they're they're not I
wouldn't call them terribly well
informed so they'll all we'll start
there
so ample fodder for conversation this is
the first thought is that if
mainland China well first of all I've
been I've just been very impressed with
the geopolitical
both a visible and invisible or less
visible strategies that have been
deployed by the People's Republic It's
always seemed very much
long-term investment
versus Aid like you mentioned and
it seems to me like if if mainland China
wanted to take Taiwan there are many
things that would suggest they could do
it non-violently
there are other ways for them to isolate
Taiwan just as an island they're
probably multiple ways they could cut
off various types of access they don't
have
it's not as easy for allies to
say
Supply Aid to Taiwan compared to say
Ukraine where there's also sort of
imminent neighbor threat that is
perceived
in Europe
so that's the first thought to me is
that it doesn't seem like it would
actually be that hard if they were to
approach it and say hey look guys nobody
wants a violent I'll come here you're
going to be on your own maybe the U.S
steps in probably not
your military yes you have mandatory
service but let's be real you don't get
a whole lot of practice
I have to imagine that to your point
though moving quickly could be to their
benefit
and secondly and again then you can rip
all this to shreds
second is more an observation that
perhaps even if we are totally inept
we are still saved
in the sense that
China and the US are so economically
entangled
that China could end up being like the
rider on the horse and the horse is the
U.S but they can't shoot their horse in
the head like they still need the horse
whether that is a byproduct of
a lot of Reserve currency in the form of
treasuries or US dollars or whatever or
trying to sustain exports to their
domestic economy doesn't
face all sorts of issues
the question then I guess is
do you see any either of those holding
any water
do you think to take Taiwan it would
escalate
putting aside the Trump intervention
to a a physical Hot War type of conflict
the challenge for
for Beijing is that the kind of softly
softly approach
which was essentially to use economics
and information Warfare to bring Taiwan
closer to the PRC has failed yeah and it
was obviously failing back in 2020 when
all Chinese efforts to influence the
Taiwanese election came to nothing and
if one looks at the sentiment of the
Taiwanese population it has gone not in
the direction of full Independence but
it leans towards
we like the status quo and we'd
ultimately like Independence one day so
the direction of travel in from the
vantage point of Beijing is very
uncongenial yeah that's the first point
the second point is that there are
things that you can do short of an
amphibious Landing
blockade being the obvious one and they
sort of showed us that they could do
that
but a blockade's an acts of War even if
you haven't landed the troops on the
beach you're still using coercion to
to us our control over Taiwan and this
is where U.S policies is crucial
the US has had for half a century more
or less a policy of strategic ambiguity
where it's not quite clear
what we would do in such a scenario we
acknowledged this was one of Kissinger's
achievements the one China principle
we don't treat Taiwan as an independent
country formally on the other hand we
reserve the right under 1979 legislation
to prevent any violent
change in taiwan's current status the
problem is we really moved away from
that ambiguity in the last couple of
years
it began I think
with
discussion in foreign policy Circles of
strategic ambiguity do we really need it
Richard Haas wrote a piece about that
for foreign affairs but now Biden
himself on three is it four occasions
has talked as if there's no ambiguity we
will definitely defend Taiwan
and and although those statements have
been walked back we've succeeded in
signaling to the Chinese that we're no
longer committed to strategic ambiguity
and
we also keep talking about practical
ways in which we will make Taiwan a
porcupine
as able to defend itself as we we made
Ukraine we also in addition to that
treats Taiwan de facto as an independent
country when someone like Nancy Pelosi
goes there yeah and every single aspect
of her behavior is that which you would
expect the Speaker of the House of
Representatives to engage in in an
independent country so I think from
beijing's point of view we have shifted
our position on Taiwan
in a way that is profoundly troubling to
them because XI jinping's number one
priority the reason he extended his time
in office let me be clear about the
number one reason he did that was to
take Taiwan under the control of the
Chinese Communist party so if we are
saying actually no ambiguity Taiwan is
an independent country and we'll defend
it that is a major problem for Xi
Jinping
so I think that's why even a blockade
would
Force the United States to take action
I don't think there's a scenario in
which this Administration would sit back
and say oh well never mind that's just
the one China policy
now my short-term memory is failing
because the second question you asked
was no they're really there were two
elements the second element was the sort
of mutual life support yes situation yes
no absolutely so clearly this is
something very different about Cold War
II
the economic ties between the United
States and the Soviet Union were minimal
and trivial
whereas chimerica still exists now this
was one of my favorite neologisms back
in 2007 I came up with chimerica to
explain the near Fusion of the Chinese
and American economies
but I also use that word
to make a pun on the word chimera so the
argument in 2007 was this isn't
sustainable folks and sure enough it
hasn't been
I think there are still many people in
the US who can't get past the extents of
U.S investment in China Chinese
investment in the U.S the trade deficit
is still enormous we buy a lot of
Chinese stuff
and they say and therefore we can't
possibly have a conflict
sometimes this takes the form of there
won't be a war over Taiwan because both
sides would be so economically hurt by
that and I call this the theory of
mutually assured Financial destruction
the problem with all of this is to
switch analogies you could have said all
of these sorts of things about the
United Kingdom and Germany on the eve of
1914 and indeed somebody did Norman
Angel wrote a whole book called the
great illusion saying there's no
possibility that they have a war it
would just be so financially ruinous
well actually it's true that the UK and
Germany were very very interdependent
economically in the early 1900s but they
stopped being economically
interdependent in a matter of days when
war broke out decoupling happened so
fast that it's kind of amazing to look
back on it
the Royal Navy literally cut the
submarine telegraph cables from Germany
to the rest of the world within days of
the outbreak of war and legislation was
introduced that effectively expropriated
German Nationals Holdings of British
assets the US did the same when it
joined the war in 1917. so I keep
warning people that economic
interdependence does not preclude
conflicts and you will be amazed how
fast the decoupling happens when the
conflict begins and if you don't believe
me let me introduce you to Russia
because what happened to Russia after
February the 24th was unbelievably rapid
decoupling from the Western economy not
the world economy they're still able to
trade with China and India but they
really got switched off
very aggressively by sanctions imposed
immediately after the outbreak of War so
I think it's clear that our Playbook is
very sanctions Reliant and the Chinese
know this and so they know that in the
event of conflict they will face
aggressive American sanctions and I dare
say going back to your point about their
ability to plan that they are hard at
work in fact I know they're hard at work
right now to try and sanctions proof
themselves and also to make sure that
any measures like that blow back on the
U.S
and cause significant harm to U.S
economic interests too so I don't rely
at all on the economic interdependence I
don't think that's any way an obstacle
to conflict it just makes the conflict
really expensive but hey World War one
was really expensive didn't not happen
hmm
so is there anything then
going from
Observer
and student of History to spotter of
patterns is there anything that you're
doing right now or would like to do as
an agent of change to try to steer
things in any
direction or another it doesn't have to
be specific to China it could be
I would be strange if I just sat in my
study at the Hoover institution having
conversations like this and then going
and playing tennis
so part of what has been
Central to my life in the last decade
has been trying to apply history
to contemporary problems and then do
something about it
that means mostly advice I'm not
probably that well suited to
political office I don't have any
aspirations to be
Henry Kissinger I.E go from being a
professor to being National Security
advisor that's not really a plausible
trajectory for me
but I think
that in advising people in
decision-making positions I can I can
achieve something so
there are a couple of aspects to this
one is that about 10 years ago I created
something called Green mantle which I
think you mentioned in your nice
introduction green mantle is an advisory
business that works with a relatively
small number of mostly Financial clients
just to understand the world using the
application of history and
it's been a way for me to do work that
is off the radar not in the public
domain that that therefore isn't subject
to the incentives that exist in the
public domain so when you do journalism
you can't be boring
you have an obligation not only to
inform it to at some level entertain
and therefore the minute you enter the
public domain you are going to make
things more interesting than they may
actually be whereas if I'm working at
Green mantle I just have to be right and
often the right answer is quite boring
and boring but important is what I like
so I'm kind of Happily engaged in
helping
people who
manage fairly large asset pools think
about how the world is going
and I can afford to be very boring and
nerdy when I do that I can I can be
quite boring on the subject of
semiconductors or I can be quite boring
on the subject of the US Treasury Market
or monetary policy or whether the
Chinese have the naval capacity to do an
amphibious Landing I I spend a lot of my
time
relishing
the nuts and bolts the granular analysis
that that makes pattern recognition
serious
punditry on cable TV is like the
opposite of that and although I'll
sometimes go on cable TV not least to
sell my books I hope I I never engage in
the kind of punditry that is just
designed to get me retweets and and
social media followers you can always
predict the end of the world and get
attention my book Doom makes fun of the
pattern where the incentives to predict
the end of the world are very strong and
world war three and one under Nick's
financial crisis You can predict that
every year
and have an audience no matter how many
times you're wrong because people will
always pay to be told the end of the
world is nigh so I'm not interested in
that I'm interested in doing the kind of
pattern recognition that gets it right
which I think for example green mantle
did in January 2020 we told clients
there is a global pandemic coming is
going to be hugely disruptive we got
that right in January right at the
beginning
of 2021 there's going to be an inflation
mess they've really screwed this up
beginning of this year Russia is going
to invade Ukraine with 80 probability so
that's kind of part of what I do and
I find it very intellectually rigorous
because unlike in Academia when you're
wrong there are consequences and being
wrong will get you fired
on Wall Street that's very good for
focusing the mind
second thing I do is talk to the people
who make policy or in the future may
make policy
and I'm always willing to
go to Washington or for that matter to
London and share my thoughts with the
people who have the very arduous task of
taking decisions under pressure and
under uncertainty with very little time
I am privileged I get paid to think and
read nobody in government has time to do
either of those things you're just in
meeting after meeting and call after
call as Kissinger said you draw down
your intellectual capital in government
because you don't have time to
accumulate any so I'm always happy to
put myself at the service of the people
who have the difficult tasks I'm
bipartisan about that I would be as
ready to talk to Jake Sullivan as I was
to talk to H.R McMaster
it's just that Jake never calls me up
but I'm here and that's what I'm more
than happy to do with all humility
because
one thing's for sure the people in The
Situation Room know things that we don't
know they just know a lot of things we
don't know and if you are in the
position of being an academic who
pontificates you should always be quite
humble because there's just no way that
you know the half of it so yeah that's
my Approach I think I think it's been
it's something I got better at
I mean I can certainly look back to the
early days when I was trying to be
involved in policy discussions
shortly after moving to the US and I was
pretty amateurish then
I think the analytical framework of the
book Colossus was correct namely the
neoconservative project to kind of build
empires in Iraq and Afghanistan will
fail and my criticisms of the new
conservative project were pretty much
right but I don't think I went about
that in a very intelligent way I was too
new
what has changed how is the toolkit
developed or the framework
how has that changed over time what has
made you more professional and less
amateur in how you approach these
discussions
doing it with a team rather than being
the solo
you know tweet Cloud superhero
ultimately these things are too
complicated and difficult for any one
person to be able to fit it all together
and know enough
so when green mantle came into existence
my policy was to hire my smartest
students to come and work with me to
think about this and see if applying
history could even work
and then crucially having taken them on
to encourage them to disagree with me
and tell me that I'm wrong
and now most of what I will say on these
subjects
as in our discussion is informed by lots
of work that other young younger smarter
people do I'll give you an example
back when the idea of Cold War II kind
of first hit me it hit me because green
mantle was doing some work on Huawei and
there was a map of the world which
showed countries that were using Huawei
technology countries that had
essentially refused to use it in the
countries that hadn't made up their
minds and I remember thinking when I saw
the map ah it's a cold war map that's a
recognizable Cold War map one side two
sides non-aligned and so I got excited
and started to think about this and I
said hey we really need to work on that
issue and that issue and what are we
doing about challenges to the dollar
what are we doing about semiconductors
and out of that those discussions came
some really good work by other people
Chris Miller's new book Chip War which I
highly recommend is the just the best
book on why semiconductors really matter
and Ike freiman has done some excellent
work on climate aspects of Cold War II
because climate's a cold war issue given
that China is responsible for a huge
proportion of the the increase in in CO2
emissions over the last 20 years so I'm
glad to say that I no longer fly solo I
work in a team I've learned a lot from
good leaders of teams how to build a
network that is greater than the sum of
its parts
and I I think that's why the quality of
analysis is better than it was
pre-green Mantle when I was inclined to
try and do everything myself and you
know that way you make mistakes I made
some terrible mistakes pre-green mental
I got interest rates really wrong in
2010 and Krugman Paul Krugman was able
to jump up and down on me with hobnail
boots on because he was right and I was
wrong and you know I learned a lot of
valuable lesson then
you know if you're gonna go out there
and do battle with Nobel laureates you
better have done your homework
so I'm gonna take a left turn here so
we've been talking about a lot of macro
issues but a lot of current geopolitical
issues
I want to ask you about fatherhood so I
have a note here
the fatherhood has been the best thing
you've ever done and as someone who does
not yet have children but someday hopes
to
could you please expand on that I'd love
to hear why that is the case
while I only have five children
uh you got some work to do to catch up
with Elon but exactly you're doing all
right there are others who've beaten me
and I I wouldn't catch up
I'm too old to have any more
children because in the end you can have
children of
at 58 but you will not be good at soccer
when they are ready for soccer and uh
you have a more obligation to be able to
go and kick that ball around
I have children who range in age from 28
down to five
and I can say unequivocally that they
are the best thing
that ever happened to me and the thing I
care people I care most about
and I never Tire of
watching them
grow helping them in any way I can
fatherhood for me has been
more fulfilling than I would ever have
imagined I think most people most men
let me say most men before they become
fathers
secretly dread
the loss of freedom
the regime of of diapers and the
prospect of being vomited on
and all of these things will happen when
you become a father you will be vomited
on diapers will become a very large an
unpleasant part of your life and you
won't be able to go
out anything like
you were able to before on the other
hand
there is something far more fulfilling
about helping and an infant uh learn
than than anything is anything else
that's available to us so
I don't know that I've been a taller
a great father I think I've been okay
and the way I would think about the role
is
is yeah it's very much pedagogical I I'm
very assiduously read to my children and
get them to read and make books a big
part of of life
I think that's that's really critical
because
these days as children grow up there are
way more distractions than there were in
in my day and you have to make
concentrated effort as a parent to make
sure that they get into the habit of
reading reading books because almost all
the accumulated wisdom of our species is
in fact contained in books and some of
these books are quite old
and unlikely to be assigned in
contemporary education so that's a big
part of it then there's all the kind of
that funny business of of
teaching children to be good
what is it to be good what is it to be
kind how does one actually convey that
how can one make a child creative
without over scheduling them with
Monday's piano Tuesdays coding
Wednesdays Mandarin you know that kind
of typical parenting and I'm I'm still
you know I'm still learning I'm still
trying to get better at it
while at the same time making sure that
all all the children got the same kind
of deal
because I'm quite egalitarian about
these things and there can be no
favoritism they all must think they're
the favorite so these are the things
that if if you gave me the chance I
would talk about with
greater enthusiasm and at greater length
and
then about anything else
but you know nobody really wants to
listen to somebody else talk about their
children it's the world's most boring
subject just like you know when people
get out their phones to show you
pictures of of their children and then
they can't find them because they have
too many pictures a little part of you
dies right because it's nice
well to me at the moment this is
interesting so since since I have the
mic in front of me I'll keep I'll keep
prying when you said I'm okay and I
might be getting the exact phrasing
wrong not great why do you say that
absence because absence passive my
life's journey took me away and
continues to take me away from my
children quite a bit
there's that great moment in one of the
Austin Powers movies daddy wasn't there
yes we all love that Austin Powers in
our family and it's part of being a
Ferguson that you watch the Austin
Powers movies much earlier than is
appropriate
but I've I've been away a lot I mean I I
was
I was so negligent as to take a job in
the United States in
2002 or thereabouts when I had three
children in school in England and my
then wife wouldn't move and I remember
saying well if I stay if I don't go I'll
I'll regret it so I'll commute
and that that was a little bit crazy and
I wouldn't advise anybody to do that I
met it meant that I was away quite a lot
it probably made the breakdown of the
marriage inevitable
so yeah you know I I think my older
children would all agree that they
didn't see enough of me and
and I've had to compensate for those
absences by
you know trying to be
present in in other ways
so you know it's difficult I think the
truth is that if you're trying to
lead three careers as you said at the
beginning
if you're trying to do good academic
work and at the same time
engage in some kind of
public life and then also do all this
advising
sure you're gonna you're gonna work 17
hour days and you'll be in New York
and Washington and London and I used to
travel to the point of insanity prior to
the pandemic
and then the pandemic stopped that
forced me to stop and for a year I lived
in Montana and I didn't travel more than
about five miles from the house and so I
saw the two younger children every day
and it was wonderful it was wonderful my
my now 10 year old and I would go for a
walk
every day we called it the philosophical
walk and it was after he'd done with his
schoolwork and I had sort of done enough
work on my then current book and we
would just have a walk hmm I wasn't
doing that before and I'm doing it less
now so
no no I'm not going to get great but the
test is always
are your children going to turn to you
in the moment of crisis are they going
to tell you the good news when there is
good news
are you able to remain in contact even
when there's a great distance
geographically between you
and on that basis
you know I think I get a B plus
and I and I would say to anybody who's
highly motivated super driven type A
personality
do what you have to do but remember the
relationship that you have with your
children is more important than anything
else and on your Tombstone it doesn't
say
wrote 150 emails a day or closed X deals
or it doesn't say publish 16 books
that's not what the gravestones say they
talk about whether you were a good son
whether you were a good husband and
whether you're a good father that's the
gravestone
people forget that
but that's the gravestone
so mortality is as good as stepping
stone as any to the the next question
which is also related to parenting
and this may be
a set of comments that are locked in the
Amber that that you would revise so I'd
be curious to hear your thoughts so here
goes it seems that based on some of the
reading I've done several things one is
that you have
been inoculated against religious Faith
yourself on some level but two that you
believe your children should understand
the Christian Frameworks since and I
think the quote you used it is still the
operating system of North America and
most of Europe
would you mind saying more about that is
that a misquote did I find that
on The Daily Beast I don't think so I
don't think so most reliable source I
was brought up an atheist my parents
left the church of Scotland
Presbyterian established church in
Scotland mainly I think because of the
sectarianism that was Rife in Glasgow
the enmity between Protestant and
Catholics which dominated the kind of
culture of the the city in in their day
and also because as scientists they they
embraced a kind of robust Enlightenment
skepticism about about religion and this
was therefore not a decision that I took
we just didn't go to church and when we
talked about those questions my my
mother would say
life is a cosmic accident deal with it
so that was how I was raised high five
go out and play and uh in practice my
parents were still Presbyterians we had
all the kind of classic
calvinist behaviors
work ethic all that stuff deferred
consumption
feeling of superiority which I think is
inherent in being a member of the elect
it's just there was no God no afterlife
and at the point of death your body
began to decompose them all the duty
without any of the payoff yeah so it was
kind of ultimately uh
it worked for me and um
I don't think there's any kind of way I
could
find to religious faith I would I would
just I would feel a phony yeah on the
other hand I don't think it's a good
operating system for a society and all
attempts to build a society on atheism
have produced terrible Horrors
I mean think Soviet Union
anti-clericalism
anti-christianity doesn't have a great
record
so I came to the position partly under
the influence of Oxford religious
observance as opposed to belief is very
beautiful in Oxford and Cambridge
perhaps more beautiful than anywhere
else the choral tradition in in
anglicanism is one of my favorite things
and I think it offers not only some kind
of consolation but it also offers social
connections that you won't form in the
workplace so I came around to believing
that although I didn't have religious
faith I should take my children to
church and I should make sure that they
were educated in Christianity and indeed
in in other belief systems but that
Christianity would be
the leading
faith in our lives because it's the
leading faith in our civilization still
and it's silly to be ignorant of it it
is the operating system Tom Holland has
this terrific book Dominion which points
out that although we think we're secular
in reality we are still a highly
Christian Society and
I think that's dead right
so you know everything gets colored by
the assumptions of Christianity even the
discussions on issues like climate
change which are supposed to be
scientific and Truth fears of the
Apocalypse the millenarian mindset are
deeply rooted in Christianity so I think
it's a slightly odd position but not
without its precedent to be in a church
without real Faith but with a kind of
respect for religious observance and
and I hope that
the
ethical Legacy of Jesus Christ does not
go extinct because I don't think you
become a good person spontaneously as a
result of darwinian natural selection
no that's just not plausible and so if
you can if you can use the Bible as a
way of helping your children find their
way to being good
then I think that's to be encouraged
even if you're as skeptical as I am
about the existence of God the
possibility of an afterlife all the rest
of it so you mentioned earlier hitch one
of your friends and as you describe this
what I would love to know is
did you explicitly explain to your kids
when you took them to church what you
were doing in other words
there's historical significance to this
I don't believe we're automatically
shaped into good moral human beings by
evolutionary pressure therefore
this is why I'm taking you to church or
did you simply expose them and run the
risk of them becoming die hards
uh and uh sort of engendering a lifetime
of head-butting with your children how
explicit or non-explicit did you make
things
I'm very explicit about things like that
I think children
shouldn't be treated as children
which will sound slightly paradoxical
but it's a good idea to treat your
children as an intelligent
many adults
and I'm sure Thomas who's 10
understood it once I'm not sure Campbell
knew what I was talking about but he's
only five
so
no I think I'm clear about this and we
talk about it look we we have a very
interesting religious
Heritage as a family my my wife Ayan is
an ex-muslim an apostate who left the
religion that she was brought up in
having had a period of
of devout adherence as a as a young girl
so we come at religion
in a kind of unusual way and so these
things do get discussed and Thomas is a
very articulate boy so it would be
impossible to take him to a church
without there being some
initial discussion and explicit analysis
of motive
so you mentioned ions we might as well
mention her again ion her CLA people
should look this name up how has your
time with Ayan changed how you view
Western philosophy maybe even View
the world or reality
per se I have to imagine I mean just
given her life's experience her
trajectory that is so difficult for
either well I'll speak for myself for me
too
Envision in uh
in any experiential way right
how was your time with her affected
how you view things I know that's a very
broad question but I'm going to leave it
Broad
anybody who hasn't read
one of my wife's books should do
something about that I on her see Ali
Infidel is a pretty good place to start
that's her life story or early life
story which gives you a sense of what it
was to grow up as a girl in Islam in
Somalia to live in Saudi Arabia to live
in Kenya to experience radicalization to
be a member of the Muslim Brotherhood
and then to go to the Netherlands to
escape an arranged marriage
to gradually be exposed to Western
freedoms to begin to question
Faith eventually to lose that faith
to become embroiled in the controversies
that followed 9 11.
to become a national figure in the
Netherlands A Member of Parliament then
to be the target of of a fatwa of death
threats all of this is in there and it's
an extraordinary story
I've learned that the story there which
is
startling and memorable in many ways
is the tip of an iceberg a very
deep trauma
I think that's the only way to to
describe it and
we're still kind of
learning about that and learning how to
deal with it
so
for somebody like me who led a happy
life in a loving family where I was
given every encouragement
it's
tumbling to
think of a life so different so much
harder
and to realize that that's the life of
millions and millions of of girls all
over the world so that's point one point
two is and I dedicated the book
civilization to Ayan for this reason
we take for granted the freedoms that
we are given at Birth
and it's very hard not to take them for
granted if you grew up with the freedom
of speech and political Freedom the
freedom to organize the freedom of
Association all of those freedoms
but when you
when you get to know and love somebody
who didn't have those things and had to
be persuaded by experience of their
value then you see things in a different
light and I I learned more about the
value of the Enlightenment from my arm
than I I could have learned from any
other source
and that's partly why civilization is
dedicated to her because you've got to
see the benefits of a free Society
with the eyes of somebody who's lived
under um freedom
with all the Discrimination the
handicaps of
being a girl in a strictly Muslim
Society fully to appreciate them
that's second the recommendation
on the read this story is is really
Beyond remarkable that's another
statement and
he mentioned the fatwa how do you both
relate to
safety and fear
how do you think about
how much weight to give to fear of what
could happen and I ask especially in
light of
the not so distant attack on Salman
Rushdie as an example right it's it's
not like
fatwas are just forgotten it would seem
I mean I know there's a lot of coverage
around that many different takes but how
do you think about living life
and how much weight to give to fear what
could happen versus
versus other factors
well I would speak for ION it would be
untrue for me to claim that she
doesn't feel fear yeah the um
the attack on Salman Rushdie was
a heavy blow
for us because it was a reminder that
these death threats don't have expiry
dates there's no statute of limitations
but fear I'll answer on my
own behalf is not a factor
I don't fear these people
and
I credit that to
a Scottish upbringing
my grandfather's faced far greater peril
in the world wars
uh my
father's father served on the Western
Front in one of the Highland regiments
as a as a teenager
and my mother's father was in Burma with
the Royal Air Force fighting the
Japanese
they they had reasons to feel fear I
don't and
I have a complete contempt for
terrorists
that is not fake
I moved to United States after 9 11
because
I was supposed to give us a lecture at
NYU on I think it was
9 12.
and of course I never gave that lecture
couldn't fly
but it kind of made my mind up to move
to the US and to take a job at NYU which
is what I did I resigned from Oxford
shortly after
9 11. that's that's definitely wasn't I
don't think I thought it through quite
at the time but it was undoubtedly the
the Scottish impulse to March towards
the sound of gunfire
and ever since I've known Ayan
I've felt a powerful obligation to
protect her and make sure that she is
kept safe
but
never fear
because
historically we Face many dangers
one can see that the world is much less
dangerous than it was in many respects
another respects more dangerous than
it's ever been
they didn't have to worry about nuclear
war the risks of
catastrophe are in some ways elevated by
the advance of Science and in other ways
science is reducing our our
vulnerability extending our lifespans
giving us a shot even if we're diagnosed
with cancer
and I keep telling her and others the
dangers
that we Face includes terrorists but the
probability
is probably higher that we have an
automobile accident or one of us gets
diagnosed with cancer so be not afraid
and
the culture which I love about my part
of the world the culture of Scotland is
we don't we don't feel fear
you can do anything to us but you can
actually frighten us and if you're
brought up with that
if that sort of really drummed into you
that's a great source of of strength
because one fears
odd things
I've always been more afraid of of
losing my reputation or my honor than
losing my life
but the things that the terrorists want
to induce the kind of fear they want to
induce that is entirely foreign to me
and I defy them and I despise them
and I will use everything I can do
to thwart them because ultimately
their threat is a
it's a threat that you can thwart
Solomon Rusty made a terrible mistake in
announcing that he was dispensing with
security and saying at the time he
published his last book I need to live
my life I said at the time that was a
mistake
and it was
that is not our approach
but no fear no way hmm
thank you for answering that
Neil we've covered a lot of ground
is there anything else that you would
like to
to share discuss any closing comments
anything at all you'd like to request of
people listening
anything you'd like to point their
attention to before we wind this round
one to
to a close
given that the risk of cancer is not
trivial when you're a 58. your old
Scotsman I I don't have anything else to
say because if I say anything else I'll
be late for my dermatologically
on the basis of rational assessment or
risk I really better shut up I must go
to my dermatologist which makes perfect
sense Neil and just for people listening
who don't get the the visual spelling
here
n-i-a-l-l on Twitter at nfergus n f e r
g u s thank you so much for taking the
time today I learned a lot I have
copious notes I have many things to
follow up on and it's nice to see you
again so thank you for making the time
thank you Tim and for everybody
listening we will link to everything
that we discussed all of the books all
of the resources anything and everything
at tim.vlog podcast just search Ferguson
or Neil n-i-a-l-l and it will take you
right there until next time be just a
little bit Kinder than is necessary take
care do not be afraid and thanks for
listening